[Music]
movies are big business and major
studios earmark their spots on the
release schedule years ahead of time as
such isn't too early to start making box
office predictions for 2018 there are
dozens of promising projects slated for
release so here are some of the movies
that are going to blow everyone away in
2018 han Solo
now that rogue one has proven that the
Star Wars Galaxies is viable even
without Jedi the Han Solo prequel with
old and Ehrenreich taking over the role
from Harrison Ford has sturdy a legs
than r2d2
the film co-directed by Phil Lord and
Christopher Miller co-stars TVs Emilia
Clarke and Donald Glover and it looks to
shed light on how Han became such a
swaggering state scoundrel in the first
place Han Solo's faithful fans should be
eager to see a story from his younger
days but the big question remains will
we finally get to meet Chuy's family on
the big screen hopefully the answer is a
resounding no we'll find out on May 25th
2018 Avengers infinity war if we had to
pick a shoo-in for smash of the summer
it has to be infinity war the MCU was
really all been building up to this
moment Iron Man and his Avengers the
guardians of the galaxy spider-man
Doctor Strange and Captain Marvel
everyone's going to be there for the big
battles beginning this is the
blockbuster of the year no doubt about
it and it launches on May 4th 2018 the
predator kicking off a new round of
interplanetary big-game hunting the
predator finds writer director Shane
Black who was one of Arnold's fellow
soldiers in the 1987 original making a
long overdue return to the franchise
blacks promised to make it the biggest
predator yet on february 9th 2018 with
the help of sci-fi savvy stars Boyd
Holbrook and Olivia Munn bye boys for
life by the time bad boys for life hits
theaters a full 15 years will have
passed since bad boys 2 when Detective
Mike Lowrey played by Will Smith and
Marcus Burnett played by Martin Lawrence
decided that they were well they're boys
for life it's a romantic sentiment which
is obviously true if they survived
another decade and a half together
little is known about what the duo will
be getting into this time but
if there's anything like the first two
films it's bound to escalate quickly now
back up put the gun down and give me a
pack a tropical fruit bubblicious some
skills Pacific Rim uprising the domestic
recedes for 2013 Pacific Rim or a bit of
a disappointment but the guillermo del
toro film was well liked by those who
actually ventured out to see the stylish
sci-fi showcase even though the
lackluster North American ticket sales
of the first film seemed to put the idea
of a follow-up in the unlikely column
international audiences always ready for
a monster fight gaze produces enough
motivation to justify green lighting a
second round of the kaiju Smackdown John
boyega joins the cast as the son of
Aegeus Elvis character from the first
installment expensive release from
February 23rd 2018 ant-man and the wasp
so many and to them was one of the most
enjoyable entries in the MCU to date the
tiny title character played by Paul Rudd
was as earnest as they come and the
Honey I Shrunk the kids ask visual
spectacle of the movie was just pure fun
the final ad to set the stage for hope
Van Dyne played by Evangeline Lilly to
finally suit up alongside our hero so
for those who have relished the wasps
adventures in the comics it's about time
we get to see a fly and at least we know
that ant-man provides infinity war right
we all find out on July 6 2018 wreck-it
Ralph to Disney's wreck-it Ralph was a
commercial and critical success I found
a way to entertain kids and parents the
Seljuk for the 8-bit era we know john c
reilly and Sarah Silverman will return
to voice our unlikely heroic duo but all
that's been revealed so far is that
it'll be released on March 9 2018 and
Ralph's will be wreaking havoc on the
web this time around and we already know
that wily is an Internet expert so we're
in good hands
in 1971 bill gray presented Michael
Sartre would it be cool if I can
remember my biggest password for my
email they'll be cool black panther of
the marvel cinematic universe is
expanding even further in phase 3 with
ryan coogler is black panther branching
out to Wakanda
to focus on Chadwick Boseman pachala who
made his debut in 2016 Captain America
Civil War with an all-star cast
includes Oscar winner Lupita Nyong'o and
Dana Herrera along with frequent Googler
collaborator Michael B Jordan Black
Panther is poised to continue the MCU
streak of box office domination on
February 16th 2018 Aquaman the brief
introduction of alpha Aquaman curry in
dawn of Justice was but a taste of
what's to come from Game of Thrones
Jason Momoa as the Trident wielding hero
will embrace his destiny as their heir
to the kingdom of Atlantis director
James 1 hounds a wet and wild action
film set to release on October 5th 2018
with Amber Heard Patrick Wilson and
Willem Dafoe also on deck 2 star
thankfully there are no green stretch
pants in sight tomb raider even without
Angelina Jolie back for another round of
archaeological badassery as Lara Croft
the Tomb Raider reboot / prequel should
fan nicely with recent Oscar winner
Alicia vikander stepping into the lead
role on March 16 2018 the new film will
take viewers back in time into an
earlier chapter from the characters
history
well killer
okay maybe not that early croft will be
on a search for her father and the
walton goggins is coming on to play the
villain the Incredibles to Disney Pixar
think reddit balls with a blast but
writer director Brad Bird took a long
break before getting down to work on a
second installment details on the sequel
are slim bursts with our live-action
comic heroes mostly just fighting with
each other lately it might be prime time
to offer up a return to good
old-fashioned villain pricing if you're
looking for a semi sequel before the
film's release on June 15 2018 you can
always dig out your gamecube and play
rise of the under miner Jurassic world
sequel after what happened in 2015
Jurassic world it might be hard to
envision a scenario that would allow the
world's deadliest steam power to legally
reopen for business but the film's box
office domination made a sequel a legal
requirement while we can't even guess
what they'll get up to this time around
we know stars Chris Pratt and Bryce
Dallas Howard are expected to reprise
their roles on June 22nd 2018 then there
will be a lot of action figures
Pteranodon shackle touch critical
opposite each sold separately Mission
Impossible 6 some cruises Ethan Hunt is
at it again
director Christopher McQuarrie returns
to helm a sixth installment of the
covert ops action adventure series while
details are minimal as to what the
actual storyline will be crews have
promised up some bunkers new stunts he
spent years trading floor will be among
the many set pieces get ready for action
on July 27th 2018 a wrinkle in time
amazingly the cherished sci-fi fantasy
children's classic has yet to be adapted
to death by Hollywood and we're not
counting the 2003 Disney Channel movie
so for director Ava Duvernay
the sky itself isn't even a limit as to
what she can do with this beloved tale
she's brought in a boatload of a listers
to help her bring the saga to the silver
screen including Reese Witherspoon Chris
Pine and professional weirdo Zach
Galifianakis put some time aside on
April 6th 2018 the flash the DC extended
universe gives Ezra Miller his turn to
shine here in a standalone turn as Barry
the flash Allen after the character was
introduced in Batman vs Superman dawn of
Justice the small screen has been kind
to the speedy hero with a CW's the flash
but
maybe not so kind to 1990 flash
so there's really no way to know which
kind of flash we'll get especially now
that the creative team on the film has
changed to multiple times and the script
has returns for our complete rewrite
still there's a good chance fans were
raised for the ticket stands and 2018
for the swamp Jungle Book not to be
confused with Disney's animated 1967
classic or the 1994 live-action film or
even Jon Favreau's live-action version
from 2016 or the slew of other
adaptations inspired by Rudyard
Kipling's book about a boy who's raised
by jungle animals and the circuses
version of the Jungle Book anticipated
for release on October 19 2018 will
speak to him in prime motion capture
form alongside sci-fi fantasy mainstays
Benedict Cumberbatch Christian Bale and
Cate Blanchett fantastic beasts and
where to find them too JK Rowling's
Harry Potter spin-off series fantastic
beasts and where to find them is on deck
for its second installment following
Eddie redmayne's Newt Scamander and his
house on another leg of his adventure
through American Witchcraft and Wizardry
following the first film's introduction
of Gellert Grindelwald played by Johnny
Depp and the mention of Albus Dumbledore
the second film is expected to begin the
battle for the ages between the esteemed
professor and his former bestie gone
rogue the film launches on November 16th
2018 Mary Poppins returns Ossipee ho
Travis might be rolling in her grave
over this one but there's reason to
believe the new installments of the Mary
Poppins story could we capture some of
the magic of the
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious nanny
and her now growing charges Emily Blunt
stars in the title role with Emily
Mortimer Ben Whishaw
Colin Firth and lin-manuel Miranda
supporting Dick Van Dyke is also
expected to appear in the film first
over 90 years old he won't be climbing
up any rooftops or cleaning chimneys any
time soon get ready for a spoonful of
Poppins on Christmas 2018 avatar 2 james
cameron has boast about a sequel to his
2009 alien adventure avatar for ages and
after years of much hype and delay it
finally probably may be actually
happening some Worthington and a Zoe
Saldana
are expected to reprise their roles with
a formally into species romantic
partners shaken the theory and somehow
Sigourney Weaver
also going to be involved despite the
death of her character but she's also
hinted that the pic might just get
pushed back again yunda expected to
cember 21st 2018 release date Maze
Runner the death cure production on the
3rd Maze Runner installment was
significantly delayed back in April 2016
due to a gruesome injury suffered by
lead actor Dylan O'Brien on the set the
spiced-up setback and the middling
domestic box-office return on the first
sequel the Scorch Trials the series
third run at the big screen should kick
off in January 12 2008 een nearly a year
after its planned release date but its
promise to finally give those Gladers
their big showdown with wicked should be
enough to give audiences their second
wins and get them out for the
franchise's finish line ready player one
while young adults dystopias haven't all
done well at the box office lately
Ernest Cline's best-selling novel has
all the components to make a solid
success combined an engrossing Willy
Wonka and the Chocolate Factory meets
hacker narrative with a strong cast
including Ben Mendelsohn TJ Miller and
Olivia Cooke and blockbuster director
Steven Spielberg and you have a recipe
for success starts getting ready a March
30 of 2018 if it's anything like the
book it will be an amazing trip back to
the 80s
rampage Dwayne the rock Johnson just
can't seem to miss lately so with him on
deck to star in this adaptation of the
classic arcade game about giant monsters
for throwing city skylines for the heck
of it it doesn't actually matter that
it's a ridiculous concept Johnson will
reunite of director Brad Payton the same
pairing that brought box-office glory to
2012 journey to the mysterious island
and 2015 san andreas get ready for joint
age and killer lizards on April 20th
2018 How the Grinch Stole Christmas
apparently we haven't seen the last of
dr. Seuss's Christmas stealing character
while Jim Carrey's turn as the holiday
hating beast was enough to satisfy the
live action crowd Universal Pictures is
rebooting the original on November 9th
2018 with Benedict Cumberbatch lending
his vocals for the title role because
the first few movies on this list are in
Cumberbatch just weren't enough ladies
love the Cumberbatch it was so close
that had even been cloned I think I
would have been able to tell just the
lightest cumber musk in the box
Deadpool to Ryan Reynolds made a
triumphant return as Wade Merc with a
mouth Wilson in Deadpool after appearing
as a mutilated character in x-men
origins Wolverine the unexpected
departure of director Tim Miller is a
little troubling but Reynolds remains
dedicated to the franchise and he's
indicated that the sequel might bring a
mutant mercenary named summer no one
fought for the next round of action as
well as one more early reveal this equal
we're going to have cable
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know your love to
[Music]